griffin canning who's making his fifth
start of the season oh and three with a
4.42 era yeah fastball's 91.95 slider
curve change up and here comes brandon
belt belt who had a three hit game
yesterday including a home run and he's
swinging it's a high drive to deep
center going back his trout at the
warning track at the wall he looks up
and it's gone so the second day in a row
belt hits a home run in his first at bat
and the giants have a two-nothing lead
3-1 pitch and there's a swing and a high
fly ball deep left center field back is
trout warning track at the wall and it's
off the top of the wall now the carrum
is bouncing back toward the infield
chasing it down is the left field a good
one but into third with a stand-up
triple is longoria and here's the pitch
this is hit high in the air and it's in
shallow center field coming in is mike
trout he is there he'll make the catch
on that one and the inning is over las
vegas native tyler anderson is on the
mound sixth appearance fourth start of
the season fletcher at second rendon at
first angels are down two nothing here
in the bottom of the first tyler
anderson delivers
swing and the change up is popped up
back toward the pitcher's mound belt
comes over from first base and then
right behind the mount after chasing
tyler anderson out of there he makes the
catch
the inning is over dell is hitting out
of the number six spot he's batting 214.
here's the o2 pitch fastball swung on
and fouled tipped into the glove of
trump o2 pitch
fastball struck him out looking he got
the high strike on the inside and justin
upton didn't think so
now change up swung on and foul tipped
into trump's glove and he strikes out
the side one to the wall in the first
inning and a cold strike three top part
of the strike zone first strike out of
the night for griffith
there's a ball that's hit well out into
center field trout is going back on this
one and he will run it down on the
warning track to end the inning runner
at third base with one away for tommy la
stella one two out to right field
jastrenski has to go back on a good one
back to third to tag it'll be a
sacrifice fly
goodie comes home to score and the
angels get on the board it's 2-1 giants
chow popped out in foul territory in the
first inning at ben he'll drive this one
out to right center field this one is
logon big fly for mike trout and we are
tied at two 91 mile an hour fastball and
trout crushes it right center once again
truck on yard 02 is swung on to miss
strike three one out of comes pablo
sandoval sandoval skies this one
out to right center fields that's
twilight
trout's got a beat on it puts it away
two down next delivery he takes and that
fastball is in there struck him out
looking albert is on lead off single joe
adele will be the next batter the
one-two
swing and a missed strike three anderson
got him and he got him to chase another
change up here's the pitch
upton strikes out swinging he went back
with the chain jump away and he got him
oh and three that's another three
strikeout inning for tyler anderson he's
got seven of them through four here's
alex dickerson to try and put them ahead
he has flied out to left center and the
pitch
swing and a big chopper could be two to
second base fielded by la stella he
throws to second in time there but no
chance to double up and the giants take
the lead milner has been very good
against lefty batters and that's why
he's into phase one right here he slices
this one to left field goodwin is
chasing down in that left field corner
he'll make the catch in fair ground and
the inning is over and the angels have
two on for trout the pitch on the way
swinging there's a shot to left field
moving to his right goes dickerson he
reaches down and makes a one-handed
basket catch so trout hit one with a lot
of top spin on it two outs and it's up
to anthony rodol 2-2 out to left field
hit well dickerson moving back on it
because he was playing toward the line
unable to get there it goes over the
wall it's an rbi double the angels have
tied it up here's albert singled his
last played appearance albert hits one
out to left field toward the corner does
it have enough height now when it's off
the wall
it'll bring home two albert's gonna try
to get to second
and he is in there with a two rbi double
and the angels are on top five to three
boy that close for albert that close
for 660 in his career so here comes
chadwick trump the bases are loaded
swing and there's a high fly ball into
fairly shallow right center
in his adele he makes the catch pablo's
gonna test him he's coming home the
throw in is cut off by albert pujols and
pablo scores easily and the giants get a
run back and now it's a 5-4 angels lead
and here's the lead off magnus stremski
and this is a base hit to right field
right past pooh holtz and the giants are
going to take the lead on yastrimsky's
double swing it mike yostremski tying
runs on board potential winning run
coming to the plate stella hits one out
to right field yastrimsky moving back to
the wall that is gone
drive home safely
halos win it in a walk off by tommy
lestella